Speaker 1: I want to start today with a correction
if I get something wrong or if I'm not clear or if
I'm incomplete about something, I always try to do
these at the top of the show. I have no intention
of hiding the corrections on the back page, so
to speak, as is often the case with newspapers
or other publications. So let me get right into
that. Yesterday, I did this segment about Fox
News propagandist Tucker Carlson siding with
Vladimir Putin and sort of writing off Ukraine,
saying Ukraine isn't even a democracy and sort
of softly justifying or defending or excusing
Vladimir Putin's invasion of Ukraine. And I made
a lot of critiques of Ukraine in that segment that
are true, including that there are concerns in
Ukraine about women's rights. There is corruption
in Ukraine. There's a lack of true rule of law in
Ukraine, a number of other concerning elements in
Ukraine. But I didn't make clear that Tucker is
wrong about Ukraine not being a democracy. Ukraine
is a democracy more or less. And certainly
way more than Russia is. If you look at the
Freedom Index Freedom House Dawg, you'll see that
Ukraine is a 60 out of 100 on the Freedom Index,
which is sort of a measure of democracy. Russia is
a 20, so 60 puts Ukraine as partly free toe puts
Russia as not free. So if I didn't make clear or I
misstated, Ukraine is a democracy, albeit a flawed
one, and Ukraine is moving in the direction
of being more democratic, whereas recently
Russia has moved in the direction of being less
democratic. The Ukrainian president Zelensky
genuinely won an election, a real election he's in
over his head for sure. There were some problems
with the election, but it was. He won. He he won.
He did not control the election in the way that
Vladimir Putin controls elections in Russia. And
so this is a correction. I didn't make that clear
yesterday. Zelensky is not an authoritarian
autocrat. Vladimir Putin is, and that is a
crucial difference between Russia and Ukraine. It
doesn't resolve any other issue. It doesn't excuse
the things that are not OK in Ukraine. But I
appreciate the opportunity to make that correction